hey everybody welcome to stream Coco
yeah now you'll notice something
different which it will a my shirt let's
take a look at this shirt thank you to
the hottest girl in my high school
Christina gravy for giving me this shirt
she gave it to me last month so little
late Christina but you know better late
than never no lifts no gifts your boys
been working out uh you'll notice this
thing on my head and a different kind of
configuration day we're gonna play a VR
game that's right a lot of violence in
the world and I thought let's play a
gentle fun amazing from all from
Metacritic all the Metacritic scores
amazing VR game called moss where you
play a little mouse or your with a
little mouse I don't really know there's
something about a mouse maybe our my me
our friend is a mouse maybe not so if
you're afraid of mice probably not gonna
wanna watch the day stream if you love
great games and cute things and fantasy
settings and I think you're gonna want
to watch here's the problem oh look at
these things that's right thank you for
taking a break from HQ we're just
getting all the people from HQ who got
disqualified I can't look at the
comments today
so Jason O'Malley creeper in the corner
is gonna yell out comments that I'll
that I'll answer because I gotta have
these things over my eyes that's the way
VR works you and also the things way
down here and I can't see it so that's
fine it doesn't matter alright so uh
let's play shall we let's play what do
we have to do real quick the game audio
you know what let's uh let's just turn
it up on here yeah let's just turn up in
the old TV nope doesn't work on the old
TV yeah cool all right well for kicking
us going we'll play a different game but
so far you got to only hear my voice I
gotta say by the way PlayStation this is
the best oh my god this book is so close
this is the best headset for sure this
is the most comfortable headset we got
oh no i recalibrated wrong
I kind of hold still the recalibrate all
right here we go all right today we can
do you know what because there wasn't
any music now there's music can you hear
yeah okay there was just no music I'm
not hearing anything through my headset
but maybe I don't need to ooh ooh I got
a ball of light also I feel like an
idiot playing this but what I what do I
do
how do i how do I open it oh this game
it's gonna be all like my hands are
shackled the entire time
whoa I'm hearing nothing through the
earphones so I guess it doesn't really
matter where you turn it up or something
I can't wait by the way for like a
cordless VR situation like there's so
many cord you guys we had to search
around for like 50 cords no there now
I'm hearing it alright I got it in the
old ears all right here we go prepare
for a lot of me screaming what's up I
missed you what the hell oh yeah
Oh Moss is wonderful it says waffle
turrets alright here we go I'm not gonna
stupid smudge quick quick tip guys quick
life hack if you have a greasy forehead
don't keep putting your PlayStation VR
in your forehead cuz it'll ruin your
maus experience alright let's do it
I'm a little nervous here let's see we
got moss oh god I'm gonna have to turn
this down are you getting it through the
thing can you turn down the TV because
it's driving me crazy
yeah oh god here we go hi to another and
the journey you take together could
change the date this is a pretty cool I
feel like I'm in Harry Potter's uh
dining room alright here we go
can you mute the TV it's by the way
everything in VRS if it doesn't work it
makes you want to throw up that's
amazing the piece that had settled
across the man what this whole game is
just a book that we read a nightmare
it's the new Kindle this is the new
Amazon Kindle is just us reading in VR
be amazing all right this is very Harry
Potter s by the way all right here we go
let's go how do we get into this what do
we do oh god yeah thank you all for
watching the 24-hour marathon it was
pretty dumb there's a lot of sweating
going onto this headset and everyone's
gonna be upset at me I'm sorry all right
you know what I think we know what the
deal is with most of this I think it's
just you know I think it's like we have
to go recover something or get a ring to
Mount Doom okay let's just let's just
get going here I don't need to know all
right here we go now we're into it it's
a lot of backstory and a boss
I'll read the Wikipedia later which is
what I normally do anyway with like any
kind of movies or anything oh cool whoa
cool look at this Hey look there's a
tiny little dock right there oh there's
a butterfly needed most I'm out of the
play area okay cool well there's like a
little thing over there can I pick that
up do I look stupid you can tell me hey
there's a mouse dusk was creeping in but
she wondered what oh my god I love this
game already look at this cute little
mouse I know I'm pointing at nothing
look at this guy he's so cute
or she could also be she they've got a
little ping-pong paddle huh so ha look
out most yeah
god damn hawk I want to live in this
world this is amazing all right I've got
my globe of light can I touch this guy
oh yeah there you go pick up the crypto
pick up the Kryptonian or whatever the
kryptonite sorry I've had a lot of
coffee what if this is how Lex Luthor
this is the origin story of Lex Luthor
you first financed kryptonite use a
mouse ah what's happening oh it's my
ball of light whoa look at me
hey that's me no danger from the being
silently peering down at her I'm up here
though dude yeah hi oh I'm just gonna
scan you for any weapons this is
basically this is a game where you're
the TSA make up oh oh hey I control the
mouse oh cool all right this is awesome
by the way
this is incredibly fun oh my god I have
a sword look at this I'm gonna badass I
am look at this dude I got moves bro hey
there's a ladybug this is I know this I
feel stupid is there like a run function
I guess I just oh my god I love this
game this is so cool you're a little
mouse dude I look at these butterflies
ah butterflies freak me out a little bit
guys
butterflies are basically I'm gonna be
honest just pretty mas right is there
any difference
I don't like oh I see look at this ah
O'Malley did you see the mouse make a
little a little motion when I pulled the
thing out he was like ooh good job
O'Malley this is awesome dude this is so
cool this is just like California would
look like if there wasn't a drought for
the last 300 years this is 100% the
graphics are amazing like look at this
guy look at this is crazy okay
that's so cool and this thing it looks
incredible like look at this big shiny
box and this grass I love when you touch
stuff it kind of makes it move a little
bit is that dope
and I keep being out of the play area
which is a problem guys if they can just
figure out what's going on with the
wires and stuff I think that's a I know
it's we're basically just gonna go into
like Ghostbuster backpacks that's gonna
have to be oh what's in there ooh look
at this
I always feel so dumb moving around on
camera in VR but also if anybody hey
O'Malley so how many people in this
stream have played VR you have a lot of
people played VR down under here I don't
like it oh look at this oh when he's out
of uh but if you guys have never played
VR it's really interesting because it
makes you feel like life is 100 percent
of VR game like we're all just living in
a computer simulation for sure
here we go we got this little guy going
up here run across here jump up here do
a little jump See's boo oh come on god
my mouse does not have a lot of hops I'm
gonna say that damn it alright alright
so everybody who hasn't played oh here
we go
if you haven't played VR it makes you
feel like whoops life 100% is a giant
sim
I guess I wasn't supposed to do that all
right this is cool look at this over
here look at all this like I feel like
I'm like in a theme restaurant there's
like a little waterfall this is great
man they've really done a good oh I got
sick there for a second
they've done a good job about because
the other hard part I think about VR is
I'm using a controller which is a little
weird you know like the vibe and the
oculus you have these other controllers
but this for some reason feels more
natural to me and keeps me in the
experience oh wait a second with this
yeah the hybrid is a better cool you
just got a spell or something no don't
go don't go
it's weird I feel like I should see my
hands
speaking of VR ready player one I would
just prove your by said South by
Southwest
good reviews I think it's getting yeah
everybody in the chat who is read ready
player one and if you haven't why not
what's wrong with you where am i oh here
I am here I come I'm so cute
I can't believe Beth is not I hope Beth
is watching this dream oh you can cut
these things down this is insane I love
this little dude he's got a backpack oh
I've got a glowing isotope in my
backpack that can't be good for anybody
this mouse ends up like getting weird
powers weird x-men powers oh snap oh you
guys you got a read ready player one
it's so good I'll look it up over here
it's weird like we're in like I wonder
if this all just is like one of those
islands on a highway like cars are going
by
we're just trapped this looks I guess I
get stuff for destroying this my little
mousie I just want to pet him come here
buddy I guess I don't have hands in this
world I could pet you with this
hey pal all right well fair enough
you're my little butt dude I'm in love
with this moss
is my name moss hey I feel like it
probably is right Moss the mouse this is
great yeah so I guess there was at some
point this was like a market but then
some evil happen probably I'm starting
to get the VR sweats a little bit I'm
not gonna lie to you guys you know like
when you start feeling just a little ill
but not because this game is awesome
this game is amazing can I jump on this
thing I don't get up over here I want to
get up there can I jump under this oh
there we go
whether I look like I know I've said
this before but everything in video
games it's hard to do a pull-up by the
way and like Assassin's Creed to do up
we did it this little town man the big
bad guy and this is glue traps all right
here we go the book came out I think
about three or four years ago it's
basically it's kind of like it takes
place in the future where there's this
that where the internet has become a
virtual reality world everybody oh this
is a cutscene now hey there's a dude
this is a bad guy this is probably a bad
guy right they're all bad yeah
oh he's just looking at me he's not
doing anything all right
later dude pacifism you know anyway came
out and everybody participates in this
with rotary world called the Oasis
that's where everyone kind of lives and
the guy who created the Oasis dies and
he says I've left three keys hidden in
the Oasis and whoever gets the three
keys gets like 100 billion dollars and
control of the Oasis so it's kind of
like a corporate
dick oh no oh no oh my god Oh watching
that watching moss drown was the saddest
thing that's happened to me in my life
my entire life anyway so it's about this
kid who's trying to find the keys and I
shake myself off ooh and can I talk to
this guy I don't want to hit him there
any other moves I got I guess no I can't
do anything all right
anyway so it's about that it's really
cool and it's adds a ton of like 80s
references hi oh we did it we do have
the glow sticks
I like the hybrid honestly like I played
oh my god look it up there whoa this is
awesome look at this freakin house over
here
I like the hybrid honestly because it
kind of makes me feel a little more in
control cuz I'm so used to playing video
games like this I'm not good with that
stuff okay how do I get across here this
is crazy can you guys see first of all
can you see that there is depth to the
water can you see that it's crazy like I
could see that the water has depth and
look there's like I could see the
reflection of the house this is really
cool I gotta say you could see look at
this you can see how deep the water is
and see the reflection in the sky
amazing really amazing alright where do
we got to go here I guess let's go back
over here maybe I can't get across I'm
nervous to like murder any other mice in
this game because I want it to be
peaceful whoa
we're gonna stare me down then oh my god
this scheme is just beautiful
uh yeah I'm very excited to see ready
player on I will say I thought ready
player one could have been three books
not just one it was that awesome I am
just completely enchanted guys this is
great
alright something I can do with this oh
here we go water wheel oh wait I got to
jump on this thing I feel like right oh
this is I think I think we're gonna see
a mouse drown in a second everybody yep
yep oh he's dead he's dead oh I see I
think I got to go up also I can't see
the chat so I can't have you guys help
me out unfortunately puzzles which is
gonna be really gnarly I do like what he
comes back alive watch he's gonna shake
water off himself see look he's like I
gotta get all this water off me so cute
boom
oh look at me look at this I'm on point
you guys give it up I go in here nope oh
yes can I just pull myself up here
little scroll this just looks crazy it
just looks amazing to me Oh
cords lot of cords I'm gonna name my kid
cords Blair alright
oh not a play area sorry I cut these
shrooms No all right
this is going to be how does this work
yeah basically how do I here we go
boom ah this is definitely pets around
ER can I just jump down here yeah cut up
the middleman you know now why wouldn't
they just keep this bridge down that
seemed a little silly to me if they've
got a town omit guys maybe because I'm
going into the darkness of the wood Oh
No ah we got it squirrel he's gonna be a
dick it's gonna be a dick right look at
those black eyes
well you look dark evil black eyes I'm
nervous about thing you know being small
makes you nervous about things that are
large oh what's happening this is what
they do for cutscenes I guess well we
have a couple pieces I think these are
the three Scrolls over here you see
these pieces yeah those are must be the
three Scrolls we got my name is quill
can I do anything okay I'd play yeah I
found kryptonite what if the guy what if
my dad was just like it's just a piece
of glass put it down all right you know
you could turn the page for me I don't
need to be treated treated like a child
I've got a name bro I'm not something
with you here right now
[Music]
you fool we have to get it back to Mount
Doom and destroy it before Sauron oh
wait guys I just learned that ian
mckellen does a trivia night every
Monday in a pub in London not as Gandalf
just has himself if you live in London
go to this pub and tell you McKellen I
love him I got to meet him Beckett late
night he's a very nice guy but yes I
haven't seen him in many years and I
wonder what he's what he's been up to
you in those years oh yeah
being like in gigantic movies playing
amazing people all right okay okay we
gotta go oh he rides a squirrel weird
that's like their version of the Tesla I
gotta say I'm glad I've just finished a
book about westerns I'm glad we moved
past like horses cuz it's like who wants
a car that poops in the road you know
it's just like good lord
then you gotta you gotta like bathe your
car I'm a guessing you still have to
give your car bath but all this you know
it's like I feel like after Tesla's
we're just getting to clean energy a
horse is like the cleanest energy can
have right
just getting back to horses oh I've
fallen asleep wake up buddy Oh does he
own the pub oh maybe that's why he does
the trivia night there oh that's so cool
what is it called
Gandalf's please tell me but it's hope
it's nothing related to have TBD well if
you if you're in London go there for me
have a drink there for me have several
you know what never trust floating orbs
of light I know like Tinkerbell and
stuff it wouldn't just be so easy for an
evil creature to be a ball of light and
then just you follow it and then it's a
problem little tiny you know what it
just feels like these are tiny little
doll houses and it's awesome I jump down
woo this is so great man this is so cool
I know like generations from now this
will be looked upon as basically like
chiseling stone so primitive but it's
pretty awesome man
this is still oh my God look at let's
step behind me this definitely looks
gloomy it looks dangerous I'm ready for
some danger man yes
poly Ark you've made an amazing game
this dude is so cute but you know what
you've kind of trapped ourselves into a
corner because now I'm very emotionally
invested and what happens if I start
crying in VR you know I can't see the
game I'm gonna ruin my VR headset
because I have a feeling that I'm gonna
end up crying at the end of this game I
already I love Coyle he's so cool bird
Oh quills a girl sorry I'm really into
quill I don't want her to die I look
peaking over stuff any kind of gamer you
can destroy box is this fun whoo we got
another little thing yes I got another
piece of the puzzle
this is dope open the door I actually
feel like I'm being helpful demanded
answers starting you can't just barge in
here with your riddles
what do you know ooh what's down here is
there something down here hmm also
probably our great job with like putting
the player in a world but then that you
that feels real and that is feels like
fully realized but also this is kind of
a VR side-scroller
which is interesting because it's like I
played Resident Evil 7 biohazard which
was really fun but it's also it has the
ability to make you really sick because
you're moving around whereas this is
just like it's amazing like it's a great
idea for a you've come upon it good
that's like fun thing I think think
right now about VR is no one's quite
cracked the code yet about I don't want
to jump down there about how - the best
way to present games so it's like this
is a brand new beautiful thing I haven't
seen before come on bro
alright let's push it back
aha look at this I'm gonna say right now
that I don't trust this ball of light I
don't trust it Oh
see magical portal I knew it this is
gonna be a bad idea like who else I
thought the way she gets up on this I
love this little thing this long
animation that's exactly that's exactly
how I get him find alleges I'm like
sweetie this is like quill thinking
she's really awesome like a danger all
like time to get up on the ledge but
like kind of looking goofy that's
alright quill I love you Oh No
that's like that's me all the time
thinking I'm like such a badass but
really I'm a little mass at the sword
guys did I just find my halloween
costume quilt from the game moss that'd
be pretty dope I mean I'm like 9 feet
tall so yes danger roll that's
interesting I see this is it like this
is the difference I don't feel like I'm
at a stage in front of me I feel like
I'm in the game
like I'm in the actual stage like me
doing this I know looks really stupid
and foolish but to me I'm touching
fireflies so get off my back about it
all right
oh here we go we got a little dragonfly
over there get out of here oh we're in a
portal we don't know where we are we
might not even be in the same galaxy
whoa I don't know I don't trust glowing
orbs man all right let's go can I do
something to it
yeah that's what Myers would be doing to
quell oh oh oh let's be careful six
dangerous I don't want to see any more
drowning mice makes me too sad starting
to get really attached to quill
if kveld dies in the end of this game
I'm gonna be hey there's a giant ax well
that was cool we're starting to see the
artifacts of man
[Music]
No uh-oh whoa dear don't eat mice right
I'm not gonna have to fight this dear it
just turns into like a Shadow of the
Colossus situation what's happening here
oh here we go as I say is that true yeah
dear don't eat mice do they very nervous
very nervous I'm nervous man
I don't trust here I don't trust him
anyone horns coming out of its head and
they eat garbage oh look at this who do
we're in like Viking times look there's
like a Skyrim helmet over here this is
pretty cool
I hope at some point at poly Ark I hope
you guys are watching I hope we get a
little helmet where the ears get to poke
through and I hope I get little tiny
mouse armor because that would make me
so happy just on like a visceral level
you know like the same levels like
seeing my child born yes my priorities
might be a little screwed up but you
know what get off my back about it all
right here we go oh no I got to worry
about my own I think that is true though
I think my see another mice yay buddy
yep how's it going hope this isn't
giving your mouse cancer because there's
the only way I can patch it all right
where we going from here I think I want
to go this way this is great this is
really fun it's just he's right here
O'Malley do you understand he's just
yeah I know she it's a she quill as a
she sorry oh man I see I think this is
some kind of terrible battle that happen
is there anything over here no oh hey
look at this
wait look if I put my head close to her
that's crazy
whoa look at that I put my head closer
she knows that's interesting Oh what's
our kill count for damn it oh it's so
depressing when quill dies all right
sorry quill although she does shake
yourself out again alright here we go
let's do it
all right here we go
so there's definitely been some kind of
crazy battle plot here I was gonna try
to go over the armor but I think we got
to go under it we're gonna learn more
about what's happened here with this
crazy
[Music]
hey oh look at this whoa look at the
moon
whoa you know what
no and I'm looking around this is really
creepy look at all these swords in this
swamp this is super creepy man I'm
starting to get a little nervous you
know what there's a thing called
security by obscurity have you guys
heard about this it's basically like you
know when you hide a key in a rock Oh
God
whoa oh my god this game just got so
much more awesome security but security
is basically security about going under
the radar and I feel like that's kind of
us like we're so small we're not gonna
be noticed by these bigger things like
all these dudes fighting oh my god this
is so crazy
so I think we're safe I feel safe oh my
god can't be seen with me you're the
glowing orb I'm just a mouse this is
really cool look at this this is crazy
oh look it over there look at all these
crazy swords this is pretty dope man I
gotta say I'm starting to get intrigued
a bit this looks like water to me you
know what I will say I wish that if you
did this it did something to the water
hey my ball floated away hey my ball my
balls way over there hey you guys my
ball floated away how do I get my ball
back oh no oh man are you seeing this my
ball is up in the trees
dude look it I don't get my ball back
uh all right well Oh got the ball back
holy [ __ ] are you over here now yeah
some people suggested possibly trying a
swivel chair Oh
or the shaky is I don't know if it oh
the shakiness Oh should I sit down oh no
I think I just got killed
now you just sit down I don't need to
but you have to adjust the camera is
that okay oh yeah
do you want to just the camera is there
a chair around me now what's happening
over to your right there's a chair but
we just have to move it over to uh all
right yeah all right all right how's
this it's a bit shaky all right here we
go I think we're good yeah that's good
yeah I'm gonna recalibrate though
cool this is going well recalibration
perfect alright I think we know that oh
wow there we go perfect alright does
this feel better yeah alright are we
happier with this wake up buddy
Oh No Oh God quill how do I get quill up
oh these two Oh boom ooh whoa all right
oh my god holy Moses oh jeez
too many cords man it's alright quill
one second I know you're disappointed in
you just hold on one second okay all
right here we go it's the right side too
many cords psvr figure stuff out all
right here we go okay
whoa here we go whoo we got a little
mouse kingdom here
nothing I got moves man look out you
know got some moves oh wait
follow up on this thing nope hmm just
make a move
oh this thing okay
seems like how would anyone be able to
how would any Mouse be able to open that
store but fine get rid of the rutabaga
[Music]
yeah we do memory couple months I mean
we did Haiti because Trump made those
comments so we did Haiti kind of
impromptu so that was I got a text on a
Sunday that said you're going to Haiti
on Wednesday unluckily have no life so I
went I was lucky enough to go I should
say but yeah we there every few months I
mean it takes a little it's a lot of
planning to get those all together so we
can't do them oh what's happening here
Oh
did I die yeah so about every couple
months I think I don't know when the
next one is geez although we know that
yes is Italy been announced yet when
it's very soon it's it very soon I think
I don't want to go here I'm gonna get up
I love that little danger role it's so
cool
also my thing is really glowing a lot
more now as well as you can see
Oh what I should have done was just run
this way is the way to go here this is
so cool a lot of I feel like a battle is
gonna take place here and call me crazy
all right
nervous I'm a bit nervous let's do it
I knew it Oh giant battle uh-oh
guys we got a front row Oh crabs what's
up bro come at me bro there's a weird
look there's a weird
kind of like a roll or something
there's my got evil guy into flames look
at that that's like an evil meat boom
and all you got man what's up Oh use my
orb to get the crab I don't need you
know what quills got it man cool is
meanwhile Oh No
oh what a way to die
I feel so bad for quill as meat well it
needs a better operator than me she
deserves better
oh that's good I don't need to do that
again anything in here yeah I'm a
completionist
I won't have time a whisper echoed
through the trees
like someone what you know maybe you
shouldn't leave a glowing shard of power
lying around just a thought maybe those
who can't keep control of their power
don't deserve it that's a big frog Vader
she sized up will with her boobies I
almost put this is so real I almost put
my controller on the table in front of
me sorry guys I got to do a quick
recovery how's everyone doing oh he's on
the show today I think right he's not
here he's not here yet he's probably at
his house no but I hear this game isn't
super long but you know what I feel like
I'm just gonna I need to just wreck some
shop with these people I'm gonna go back
and play this on my own time you guys
want to be entertained right see more
the gameplay I appreciate the story I'm
just saying the story's dope we're all
into the story might do another quick
recalde I call it
I'm into this man this game is awesome
very cool
I see why I get such great reviews very
very cool
I wonder what a psvr is going for these
days whatever it is you know it's
interesting that is actually might make
you guys want to buy a PlayStation VR I
might make it worth it is you don't need
a television you could play this game
without a TV you can watch TV or
whatever through your PlayStation with
this and it just looks like a giant
video screen it's really cool so for
those of you with small apartments or
roommates and you're not fans of you can
watch TV just like this which is cool
somebody offset the cost of buying a PSU
it's pretty immersive I gotta say and
again I think it's one of the most
comfortable headset out there whoa look
at this yup you think I ain't learning
from my mistakes
boom these dudes can't look kind of like
little Boba Fett's if Boba Fett was a
mouse and had a sword and shield
he'd look exactly like these guys or you
know what it kinda looks like a little
halo little Master Chief II all right
again I don't know if you're a mouse how
you're gonna get this door open but
luckily I'm here to help
oh I think I got some extra stuff died
am i more like a glove now or is that
like a point and I get did I get
poisoned Oh a puzzle perfect while I'm
real dumb this is cool though look at
this no now with this I think that the
way Polly arcs done this is really smart
because I don't feel again there's not a
lot of movement it just there's enough
movement to make you feel like like
there's enough parallax which is by the
way the term of how we see distance
right
there's no parallax to make it feel like
this is a real world but I don't feel
dizzy or sick at all which is great and
again I think that's part of the reason
why I like the hybrid thing because I
feel very in control I don't need to
think about oh I'm moving this guy
around cuz that's just how I move stuff
around you have a little arm or
something what's going on there I got
look I have a little arm her arm and I
got a cooler sword I think look at this
that's dope look out [ __ ]
all right oh I thought this is a puzzle
I guess not I'm just moving ahead or no
all right very cool sound designs great
to know again I felt a little sick with
Resident Evil 7 not super sick not sick
enough to make me not want to finish the
game but that's why I really like the
layout they chose and like the style
they chose this game
you can give your boy some stuff in the
pots that's all I'm saying you know Jeff
I don't want to see a drowned Mouse
danger all huh oh wait a second so you
got a bit of a puzzle on our hands how
does this work
I can't lift it higher can I move this
no all right I like it like a challenge
I bet I could go right over this way
here we go pow pow pow I don't think in
real life I've ever been able to smash a
pot so I'm happy to do it in a game
that's why it always makes me so happy
dunce keys look at that that danger all
never gets old
oh and look there's something back over
there by the way how crazy would it be
if you were just like hiking and you
came upon this little like Mouse world
and when these guys were fighting uh-oh
this is gonna be a problem when these
guys were fighting they didn't see like
this little mouse with this is kind of a
big mouse world like look like that's a
human you could crawl down in here and
be awesome this is the coolest like
hamster hamster trail thing I've ever
seen all right I guess we just got to go
and do it man
I can't destroy him on the thing huh
can't get me no that was sad seeing my
little guy get killed my little gal way
I can hold down l2 and r2 and put oh
shoot I'm not gonna kick something here
we go quick stone a alright let's do it
danger roll let's do it let's bring him
close oh yeah oh that's so much easier
we got to work together quill us too
you miss boy
oh my god it's so easy whoever gave me
that tip thank you because nobody wants
to see me die again as a mouse Oh what
now what's up I know screaming it tiny
little virtual reality crabs but oh this
is how we take out the plutonium perfect
nailed it
let's get up the stairs boy this is
great I'd have to turn this or something
I know I look dumb doing it okay nobody
needs to say that I know I look like an
idiot
there he goes there she goes cute little
butt wagging around alright yes I will
be jumping up here no I won't oh well at
least we didn't see your die you know
thank goodness for small favors uh-oh I
got to go up around that way alright
the design of the sword looks like it is
dude look at that you know how that
looks that looks like that looks like
the sword who soar does that look like I
don't know it's a bad I sorta kinda
looks like the dude from Spartacus not
Spartacus I'm from 300 general Leonidas
calyx like his sword I think pretty dope
all right uh how do we do this oh well
well that seemed um what's happening
here I can't get up there you're gonna
pull it out oh wait I want to be on this
side of it carry me buddy
it's a pretty brave little mouse I can't
believe the mouse isn't scared at all no
I can't no oh I guess I got to push it
okay I am a little too close to the
camera for this to work properly can i
push it back no other way bro other
other way bro get son of a god damn it
alright well that's not gonna work uh
let's break these pots always satisfying
breaking the pots you know how do we get
up there I think you got to push this
thing in that's what I think you don't
think you push that thing in is there a
hole in it yeah I gotta pull it out
there's a hole in it
no no hole I can't get up there you know
what I was bitching about having puzzles
that weren't hard enough and now the
first puzzle that's just a little bit
hard I can't seem to fix I guess it
doesn't go yeah I'm there's definitely
something I'm stupid about right I can't
twist it everyone is just so angry huh
I can't get it out far enough that's
what she said
about this block she was playing this
game I think it's something where I'm
supposed to I frankly think I'm supposed
to push it in but it's not yeah don't
get impatient okay quill I know I'm dumb
okay
you've chosen a stupid human is your
helper apologies in advance you don't
think I'd push it in all the way that
seems to me like the thing I just think
like I can't because of where I am you
know what I'm saying
don't you think I should push it all the
way that just makes sense I can't get up
here otherwise oh wait push it to the
right I'll pull it out and push you to
the right it's not gonna work I'm
telling you guys I'll try it
of course maybe I shouldn't be like such
an idiot if like the people Oh push to
the left this way right but you want to
go this way that you do this way pal huh
I can't push it to the right Kenny
hmm now see I would think you can slide
it over this way are you googling how to
do this
[Music]
you don't think it goes out for damn it
I gotta see what's up there and over
there and get that little thing perfect
oh that's a good idea
nope
oh you know what I try oh who said that
Sam way to go Sam you know what if I had
paid attention to environmental clues
and not been an idiot
I would have been able to think that
myself thank you Sam you get the you get
the blade helper MVP award for this
stream yeah oh look this is my favorite
animation do it yes so great and I got
to push this dumb thing back
I'm gonna run this way it literally was
like the easiest thing of all time I was
dumb see guys that's my that's my motto
in life as well in games you first you
don't succeed just give up and ask the
chat for help and in my real life I
don't have a chat and that's why I don't
get very far in life cuz I just give up
nothing happens here we go but quill is
not gonna give up clothes got the danger
roll quills gonna jump up here well it's
gonna do this actually so we're closed
gonna do oh my god we got Scrolls on
Scrolls up ah nice try dude what is this
ah ro I like how he looked around
oh you know what maybe we gotta get this
dude to stand on the thing right or
something we think that that's a thing I
think we can get him to stand on this
thing and it'll open up stand on it I'll
kill you
stand on it you dick stand on it come on
come over here there we go
did it well look at me I'm the captain
now
I mean don't look I can't see you if you
look at me but oh man we got multi level
dudes over oh this is gonna be a pain in
the butt I can tell you right now hiyee
[Music]
there's while you can help me out
this is tough man what time we got a
mouse oh man all right well this looks
like a tough puzzle so I think we're
gonna call it for today oh wow that is
sweaty thank you all for joining us this
is awesome the game is moss it's super
fun and really really engrossing and I
got a little emotional guys I'm pretty
attached to quill our little mouse she's
super cute and she's starting to get
some armor so I might take this thing
home and play it because it's amazing
I thank you all for joining us make sure
to watch the show tonight on the show
bill burr no other awesome people are on
tonight I don't know I'm still stuck in
the world of moss it's amazing I want to
go and live there but I'm too big I
would crush everything thank you all for
joining us we'll see you guys next week
see you later bye